our friend Congressman Jamie Raskin
who's been a guest on this program says
that Donald Trump will likely end his
life Behind Bars this I have to see
because I have a very very difficult
time believing that Newsweek reports
Trump likely to be indicted will end
life quote Behind Bars Congressman says
former president Donald Trump will
likely be indicted and spend the rest of
his life Behind Bars representative
Jamie Raskin said on Saturday Raskin is
a Maryland Democrat and served on the
house select committee investigating the
capital riots the panel spent months
probing Trump's role in the Insurrection
okay Raskin reflected about the
significance of the report issued by the
committee during an appearance on Yahoo
news's skullduggery podcast Saturday the
Democratic lawmaker said he quote would
be really would be surprised if attorney
general Merritt Garland did not indict
Trump for his alleged role in the riot
adding that it's so clear that the
president intended to interfere with the
election certification Raskin went on to
say I do think it's very very important
that we establish that it's not just
foot soldiers but kingpins who are
prosecuted and that it's just wrong to
send hundreds of foot soldiers to jail
and leave the very clear Kingpin
unprosecuted he added that Trump could
spend the rest of his life in prison if
he's convicted on January 6 charges
there's just deep culpability from the
very beginning and on everything that
Donald Trump did I'm very serious about
him facing the consequences and paying
for the cost of his action he could
spend the remaining days of his
misanthropic Life Behind Bars presumably
with Secret Service agents I would love
for Jamie Raskin to be correct here I
really would the blatant criminality and
flouting of the law by Donald Trump is
absolutely stunning and appalling and we
hope that the safeguards we have in
place are actually robust and strong
enough that they can hold someone like
Donald Trump accountable I would love
for Jamie Raskin to be right that that
accountability is going to be prison
time I don't think that it is and again
it goes through let's think through the
steps first step is Donald Trump has to
be indicted hasn't happened yet but
maybe it will great Trump gets indicted
next step is does it even go to trial or
is Trump as a former president who will
have the best of the best legal advice
going to strike a deal and make a deal
either where he doesn't have to admit to
any guilt but he pays fines or he um has
to plead guilty to something minor and
the consequence of jail time prison time
is not even on the table if you get
beyond that and you say okay he's gonna
have to go to trial and it's going to
include the possibility of a prison
sentence
how do you get a jury to fairly evaluate
a former president's actions I don't
know who you can find that wouldn't
bring a strong preconceived notion and
preconceived opinion about Trump's guilt
or Renaissance and by the way as I've
said before if you can find people who
really have no opinion I would wonder
whether where they've been for the last
six years and whether these are even
really the people competent enough to
serve on a jury although it's a jury of
your peers I understand everybody gets
to serve so how do you even put a jury
together if you then get a guilty
verdict that sticks that doesn't get
appealed there may not necessarily be
prison time and if there is a guilty
verdict and if there is prison time
and Trump gets sentenced older wealthy
folks close to 80 years old with prison
sentences use every possibility
available to them every health issue
that they have and argue for house
arrest instead of actual prison so I
believe that if everything went
perfectly indictment serious charges
conviction sentencing that even includes
prison time
I think you get a suspended sentence or
at the very very worst for Trump you get
home confinement so I know he's Mr
Perfect Health 63 239 healthiest
president ever I assure you they will be
a very different story painted about his
health if all of a sudden prison is on
the table and I would bet anything
that Trump doesn't see a day in a jail
or prison cell if you disagree with me I
want to hear from you I just don't see
it